es ist der moment in dem alles
entscheiden könnte er macht klar keine
provokation hier von außerhalb wie ihr
baut scheiße baltimore maryland die
polizei ist bereit die menschen sind
wütend
jeden abend kann friedlicher protest in
gewalt umschlagen das ist gut die lange
gewachsen ist sie entlädt sich auch
diesmal genau das darf nicht passieren
meint keil wir treffen ihn an seinem
fotostudio im zentrum borth ii muss seit
jahren engagiert er sich gegen die
ungleichbehandlung von menschen jetzt
sei es zeit laut zu werden sehr laut
gehört zu werden aber friedlich ohne
gewalt das ist nicht die mehrheit die
der chaos und durcheinander stiftet wir
sind nicht alles schlecht wir wollen
einfach nur gehört werden
wir haben es satt vernachlässigt
verachtet und wie abschaum behandelt zu
werden
keil ist ein erfolgreicher fotograf
bietet fotokurse an und will für
jugendliche perspektiven schaffen weil
er perspektivlosigkeit selbst erlebt hat
seine vergangenheit sein umfeld hat
spuren hinterlassen
ich habe eine kurze zeit lang mal drogen
vertreten das lag nicht in meiner
nachbarschaft gab es ja praktisch nur
doch irgendwann sagte mal jemand zu mir
hey du bist smart als alle anderen
weißt du wieviel geld man damit machen
kann und ich so wie viele jetzt zeigt
teil anderen jungen schwarzen wie sie
rauskommen aus dem teufelskreis von
armut drogen und dem konflikt mit den
behörden
er bringt ihnen das fotografieren bei
irgendjemand hatte kein mal eine kamera
geschenkt für ihn wurde das dank seines
guten auges zum einstieg in ein besseres
leben
sein rat an die kids ist einfach ein
gramm vorbeugung ist mehr wert als ein
und heimen
hier ist eine prävention die kamera mit
der kannst du geld machen kann mir
siehst du wie das geht also los
einer der jungen männer die keil unter
seine fittiche genommen hat ist auch er
ist unter schwierigen umständen groß
geworden in der highschool wurden
freunde ermordet andere verkauften
drogen landeten im gefängnis
denn suchte den ausweg über den sport
aber als das nicht klappte zeigte keil
ihm eine alternative teil hat mir
gezeigt was möglich ist seine kamera
geschenkt mit der habe ich dann einen
haufen geld gemacht und die kamera einem
anderen weiter geschenkt hoffentlich ist
es ein segen für den sowie keines für
mich war
gemeinsam ziehen menschen schwarze weiße
vor allem junge leute in den stadtkern
von bord
sie wollen andere aus allen
gesellschaftsschichten aufrütteln wer
sich dadurch gestört fühlt ist teil des
problems hof trainerteam aber ohne eine
breitere unterstützung werden sie den
kampf nicht gewinnen
es ist nicht mehr akzeptabel einfach nur
schwarz und weiß zu sein getrennt
voneinander was wäre das okay als ich in
europa lebte haben sie mich überall
amerikaner genannt als ich zurückkam
nannten sie mich sofort liga auch kyle
ist daher dokumentiert die proteste und
hofft dass sie etwas verändern
endlich denn bisher wurde er noch jedes
mal enttäuscht starben wieder schwarze
durch polizeigewalt
das ist ja nicht das erste mal es
passiert immer und immer wieder
ich habe die wut längst hinter mir ich
kann kaum noch wütend
am wegesrand sitzt die hoffnung auf eine
bessere zukunft aber für die wird wohl
auch eher kämpfen müssen solange die
weiße mehrheit nicht mit marschiert es
ist eine hilflose wut die sich da
entlädt gegen ein leeres polizei hatte
das nur sekunden später die
polizeibeamten zur stelle sind erzeugt
noch mehr so schnell gehe es nie wenn
einer von ihnen mal hilfe braucht und
die polizei ruft gestorben dem hat
keiner geholfen und schützt dieses
verdammte auto drei beamte hätten den
einen weg schubsen können von seinem
hals keiner hat irgendetwas gemacht aber
ein auto das retten sie die liste der
bekannten opfer ist lang die der
unbekannten wohl noch länger jeder hier
der schwarz oder braun ist wie sie sagen
hat seine eigenen erfahrungen mit der
staatsgewalt gemacht den minister der
eigentlich für gerechtigkeit zuständig
wäre sieht das land am montag im
fernsehen william beier hände in den
hosentaschen amerikas justizminister
steht im park vor dem weißen haus und
gibt die anweisung die friedlichen
demonstranten gewaltsam zu vertreiben
trotz der versammlungsfreiheit die linie
der militärpolizisten rückt an die
barriere dann beginnt das schießen
gummigeschosse reizgas blend kranker
friedliche demonstranten werden
vertrieben
gleich nebenan erklärt sich der
präsident zur personifikation von recht
und ordnung vor dem weißen haus an der
saint john's kirche werden die letzten
protestler weg gedrängt weil trump
diesem fototermin
all das sei das gegenteil der botschaft
jesu so sagt später die bischöfin zu
deren diözese die kirche gehört religion
als propaganda kulisse minister als
erfüllungsgehilfen
das lincoln memorial bewacht von
soldaten vor friedlichen demonstranten
für manche ist all das ein zeichen von
angst vor dem verlust der macht
es gibt jetzt eine moderate mitte weiße
wähler die auch unzufrieden sind und das
erzeugt politischen druck den wir vorher
so nicht hatten
dieser politische druck wird dafür
sorgen dass es veränderungen geben muss
in minneapolis bietet der
sicherheitsapparat auf was er hat weil
hier wie in so vielen städten im land
auch krawallmacher unterwegs sind sie
greifen die polizei an plündern und
zerstören geschäfte es gibt eben nicht
nur friedliche demonstranten wie uns
matches erzählt hier haben viele gebäude
gebrannt
es gab auf und zerstören dabei ist
minneapolis eigentlich eine friedliche
stadt
wir sind sehr stark mit viel
gemeinschaftssinn state hat diese bilder
gefilmt auch hier sind es vor allem
junge leute die demonstrieren matt hat
uns erzählt dass es viel rassismus in
der polizei von minneapolis gebe und
eine haltung dass man mit allem davon
kommt wenn man eine uniform trägt umso
weniger wollen sie den polizisten durch
gewalt einen vorwand liefern
einer von metz freundin hat diese bilder
hier festgehalten
ein vermummter mann den die anderen
nicht kennen schlägt scheiben ein
provokateur
die anderen konfrontieren die heute
sofort verschwinden wenn du auch ein
demonstrant wärst würdest du sagen hey
ich gehöre zu euch ich bin auch wütend
über der bedeckten sein gesicht und
versucht wegzukommen
die friedlichen demonstranten wollen ihn
zur rede stellen
vielleicht ein links oder ein
rechtsextremist es bleibt unklar wird
handgreiflich und entkommt ähnliche
vorfälle gibt es in anderen städten der
usa diesen zwischenfall hat mit selbst
gefilmt das auto fuhr langsam durch die
straße der insasse feuerte schüsse ab
raste davon
mein freund waren das autor angetreten
schlug an die scheibe der sollte
verschwinden
aber der fahrer zog eine waffe raus und
schoss wir glauben dass das ein
provokateur von außerhalb ohne
nummernschild nicht von hier
ein weißer im anzug darum sich dann noch
eine durchfahrt weitere schüsse zum
glück wird niemand verletzt
die polizei ermittelt jetzt ja es gibt
die gewalt aber es gibt auch dass die
überwältigende mehrheit der
demonstranten ist friedlich wie hier in
new york entsteht ein gefühl von neuer
zusammengehörigkeit sicher auch befeuert
durch die korona pandemie und die
wirtschaftskrise
ich sagte gerade noch wie schön all
diese verschiedenen rassen zu sehen die
zusammenkommen und für etwas aufstehen
was notwendig ist eine generation die
dinge verändert
das wollen auch die die vor der haustüre
des präsidenten in washington
demonstrieren trotz ausgangssperre auch
an diesen ab sie sind ein sichtbares
zeichen für ein amerika das sich
verändert und dass sie verändern würde
sie können uns nicht stoppen wenn wir
alle zusammenstehen dann können wir
nicht scheitern deshalb seht ihr all die
rassen hier weil es alle so leid sind so
leid
wir sind es leid ich habe die flagge
mitgebracht weil sie für den sieg gegen
die sklavenhalter steht gegen die
faschisten und gegen die kommunisten
worte reichen nicht wir arbeiten
zusammen um es besser zu machen
wenn wir es jetzt nicht reparieren wenn
sich die gesellschaft weiter verändert
wir aber die macht schicht teilen wenn
wir die chancen nicht teilen dann
befürchte ich dass sich die sonne senken
wird über unserem kleinen demokratischen
experiment auf dieser seite des großen
teichs in baltimore werfen einige
gegenstände auf die polizisten denen die
unsicherheit ja sogar ein stück furcht
anzusehen ist während sie zurück
es geht in dieser nacht auch um die
frage was für ein amerika ist in zukunft
sein soll ein neues anderes oder eines
voller angst aggression und gewalt von
einigen auf beiden seiten auf der seite
der demonstranten scheint diesen hier
besonders an eine eskalation zu liegen
die schwarz vermummten weißen fallen auf
die menschen hier kennen sie nicht
offenbar wollen sie die stimmung
anheizen gewalt provozieren aber die
anderen wollen der polizei keinen
vorwand liefern demonstranten gegen
krawallmacher die welt nicht von hier
agitatoren von draußen sind das nicht
und doch wird es auch in dieser nacht
wieder ausschreitungen geben in
baltimore zwischen pandemie und
wirtschaftskrise amerika ist den aufruf